Hello internet,
I want to talk about Canada, which this week has extended my 'reason-to-like-her' list with a fact
by abolishing the one cent coin.
Because I have previously made a video called "Death to Pennies," this will come as no surprise
that this promotion has earned a big 'go Canada' from me.
Let's take a moment to cheer on Canadas economic rationalism, see how
removing a coin works in practice, and having her sister remember that she might
does the same.
Canadas plan is pretty simple: The Royal Canadian Mint will be her in a few months
to switch the device taste from on to off. That is it.
Nothing will change in the world. One cent coins will still be legal
means of payment in Canada so a pot with hundreds of coins that you don't feel like counting
worth as much as it is today.
And in stores it will still be the person who pays exactly with change.
But after they have counted their valuable money the store will take them
send back to the Royal Canadian Mint to be melted down. Provisioning one cent coins
will fall slowly over time in a pleasant half-life curve.
But, after the one cent coins fall away, the prizes fall with one cent intervals
not gone
Your coffee and TimBits will still cost the same, and when you arrive at the checkout
the total amount including tax will still consist of one cent.
If you pint, the exact amount of money will be debited from your account.
The only difference is that when you pay in cash, not with pin, * and * you don't have one cent of coins
with which you waste other people's time, the prices will be rounded to the nearest one
five cents.
And yes, with rounding you win and sometimes you lose - and this is it
salient point - one or two cents really doesn't matter.
That is why Canada can safely throw the one cent coin overboard.
Inevitably, however, this is the point in the discussion when pro-cent people say
throwing the coin away causes prices to rise and savings to fall.
But the proof of this claim does not exist because many countries have already done so
with no ill effect.
Sure, money collectors and ineffectiveness fans will be sad about the loss of the coin, but
it is a victory for Canada because making money is not free. The making of a
such a coin is around 1.6 cents
So every year when Canda visits The Mint she spends $ 29 million to $ 18 million on one cent
buy coins - $ 11 million is thrown away every year.
Logically, removing one cent of coins will not have a direct effect on the balance but it is
the easiest and most rational way to get started
Congratulations Canada! May others follow your path.
PS
If you want to know why specifically the US should get rid of one cent coins
You can watch my video of the subject or listen to fellow John Penny
those arm-waving becomes angry at not only one cent coin, but also at five cent coins, which are even worse.
A new video will also be uploaded in the following week, or the one after, but if you want to help
to make it go faster, go to my website to help check facts for coming
projects.
Thanks for looking.